it is windswept cold and empty here a
seaside resort out of season
but what happens in lugmin could yet be
crucial
there are echoes of soviet times a
former nuclear power plant stands idle
and ugly
and russian influence is still strong
here this is the nordstream 2 gas
pipeline it links germany with russia
capable of supplying enough energy for
26 million german households it's either
a precious resource or a sign of
russia's creeping control
or maybe both
angela merkel always insisted this was
just a commercial venture but in reality
nordstrom 2 is probably the most
contentious building project in the
world it's been opposed by a whole load
of leaders including donald trump and
successive ukrainian governments it ties
together germany and russia and now a
group of western allies including
britain and america
wants germany to unpick that knot to
accept the possibility of sanctions
against the russian energy industry even
the specter that nordstrom 2 could be
shut down altogether
germany well remembers the pain of
conflict between east and west and
chancellor oliver schultz has agreed
only reluctantly to embrace sanctions
including on nordstrom 2 that's a point
repeated today by his foreign minister
that he won't supply weapons to ukraine
his critics say he's too passive and
that his hesitancy has harmed germany's
reputation
i think the government should revisit
their position
and think about
supplying weapon systems to the ukraine
but when it comes
to germany we overcome the
cold war because we could rely on others
now it's up to us to support the
countries which are now on the front
line
this is a rich country with ties to
russia and an ingrained sense of dread
of another war
among this group of ukrainians living in
berlin a sense of anxiety and
disappointment
we are like the allies we are like the
friends and we're not getting the
support and it's just very
sad and we also feel like powerless at
this point that
what should we do german government has
to
show clear position but also
active things that they can do
um financial support also
support with supplies i think we need
sanctions on russia and to increase
these sanctions and to show with all
measures and possibilities that with
every russian aggressive step on
ukrainian border there will be like
harsh and quick answers and that is
germany's challenge to support its nato
allies without ostracizing its russian
gas supplies but backing both horses is
never easy adam parsons sky news berlin